and so I wanted to bring up something
that I think is quite timely which is
the difference in the public response to
your transformation and the public's
response to Adele's
transformation what your thoughts on
that I want to back up for one minute to
say that monistic
from what I've looked at in the news and
even comments I've gotten on social
media and even conversations have had in
life and it's kind of heartbreaking that
I've gotten only seemingly only
accolades you know every for every 200
comments on social media there's a guy
going you're still fat and I'm like okay
I can't win with you you're a dick
yeah nothing I will ever do will be good
for you so I'm you're not my guy and to
hear anybody say anything looks I look
at pictures of Adele at any point and I
think she's a pretty girl an attractive
girl but I see the most recent I think
there's only one picture I've seen of
her recently where she's like she is
ecstatic and she is glowing and she is
this doing a look at me picture right
and I'm like she's not nearly as happy
in these other pictures she's winning
awards and she's [ __ ] all hot she's
dope singer like all this and she looked
clearly happy but she is not as stoked
in those earlier pictures so I'm how can
you be anything but like stoked for this
girl and go like I want to Pat her on
the back and say you did great the fact
that anybody can tie any kind of
psychological [ __ ] that only exists
within themselves on to her and say that
she's harming people or whatever I think
is ridiculous you know she's a girl who
had a goal who made her goal or God as
close to it as she possibly could I have
had that in 2012 or 11 when I was
obsessively bicycling and I got what I
felt like was too thin
there were stories that paparazzi would
follow me around riding my bike and take
pictures of the loose skin on my legs
and right like the downside of weight
loss and look at how terrible he looks
like I had I experienced that so III
don't know what it is I certainly wasn't
as confident in myself then so I kind of
would see these stories and go yeah
they're right I I don't look great I'm
there right I couldn't argue with them
and this time I was releasing pictures
of myself going like I [ __ ] [ __ ] you
if you think I don't look good I know I
listen if anyone has the balls to come
up to someone who now looks like you and
say that they're a very brave person you
know yeah I will crush you to 50 cals
right I've got 150 Cal my left hand
another one in my right and I've got a
belt-fed machine gun chain of bullets or
ammo don't [ __ ] with me yeah yeah I I
don't I I think girls have it harder
than guys do as far as the aesthetics go
you know which is maybe that's publicly
because I know like guys with each other
like me and my friends are constantly
picking each other apart you know and
talking about bizarre things that really
shouldn't matter but they do matter to
us and you know how how does your bicep
Mane rest at the exact center of your
biceps or is it cocked over to one side
and how do we fix that you know we all
know we all know each of those pain
points as well right like yeah the thing
you can say to your buddy like
everyone's got that one lad friend who's
going a little bit thin a little bit
early in life you know you can always be
like dude just put something on your
head like that the shine off the top of
it killing me or you've got like the guy
that's a bit short or the guide it's a
bit whatever you know they do that and I
wonder I don't know man I was fascinated
watching the Adele situation unfold and
the layers upon layers of people saying
congratulation
adèle you've done really well this is
great you're a role model for people to
lose weight then there was the reaction
that was big girls don't think that just
because Adele's lost weight to conform
to society's beauty ideals that you need
to lose weight as well you're beautiful
too then there was the like third layer
of people that were saying how dare
these people say that she shouldn't have
lost weight this is and I'm like this is
like Dante's Inferno
we're just descending through all the
layers of Hell here like there are
certain things that are unarguable facts
a beastly is an all cause mortality risk
fact number one yeah you die sooner of
everything if you're fat so anybody that
says you singer in the public limelight
should sacrifice your health
literally sacrifice your life your
mortality your risk of everything to be
a role model for other people to also
shorten their lives that that I sort of
blew my mind but on the flip side of
that when especially when I contrasted
that with your journey I'm like wow
there is something going on here between
is it because of who you are is it
because of the industry you're in I
don't think so is it because of your
gender I think it is I thought I think
the vast majority of it is that guys
have a bigger Overton Window like a
larger leeway of guys can kind of get
real thin guys can get real fat and it's
kind of just like we just still a bloke
you know there is there is no beauty
standard for men there's like a hotness
standard but he's supposed to have like
a long hair coming out you knows that
you haven't seen once in a while which
gentleman under the age of 30 these
random things are going to begin
happening to you where you're just gonna
find like an elephant hair in the middle
of your forehead and times a cruel
mistress
um like all this stuff's gonna happen
but you're right like this this there's
still sort of this beauty standard for
women even as you get all that Dame Judi
Dench you know being grace
as she gets wards later age and stuff
like that and I don't know what it is
when I don't know what I do know is that
I was real disheartened by women's
response to Adele yeah me too
and Madden but it's some men to help
feminists who were like just looking to
please some group I think they were in
there please a women game yeah but like
girls and guys were supportive of you
yeah vast majority of guys that I saw
commenting online were either commenting
on women's slating Adele or
complimenting Adele yeah but then the
girls side of stuff do what I wasn't
seeing much vitriol from men I was
seeing a lot of vitriol from girls and
it's like hang on a second are we not
supposed to be backing our own team here
like you need to gas up the people who
you want to do well in life like Adele
is an amazing role model for girls yes
maybe that makes someone who is
overweight uncomfortable at the fact
that Adele was showing me that you can
be both successful and overweight but
now you have someone who is showing you
that if you are overweight you can be in
a healthy range not because of society's
beauty standards forget that like I'm
not playing that game I'm playing the
game of you will live longer and by the
judgement of her photo and as you
identified yourself this glow that she
had potentially be happier yeah I I
think that I think there's there can be
a lot of things that are true at the
same time which for me there does become
a level of subjectivity your health so
yes if we are urging towards long-term
survival not being overweight benefits
that sure but at the same time I go like
what business is of mine how people
choose to live you know so I'm like you
want to drink you want to do drugs you
want to drive your car too fast you want
to do reckless
you want to get coronavirus I don't
really care
don't [ __ ] mess with me and don't do
unsafe things to me and we're good
and I know there is some argument that
talks about the burden on health care
with obesity that it suddenly does
become an effect larger numbers of
people and I golike that's too abstract
for me if we're talking about
individuals how an individual chooses to
live doesn't really matter to me and I
won't criticize them I've noticed quite
a bit recently of young girls who when I
was a kid you would never see an
overweight young girl in kind of a
midriff shirt showing her belly you
wouldn't see that and I see it today and
the girls seem to have I choose girls
because this is I have four daughters
and I'm just more aware of their friends
and like what girls are doing than I am
with young guys there is a higher sense
of confidence certainly or a less of a
shame around being overweight which i
think is a good thing because i don't
think i think that it's for me there was
something about
being introverted and most of my eating
was which I do consider to be harming
myself self-harm was being done
privately because I was ashamed of it
and I didn't ever have the confidence in
myself to try and change that until I
met a girl who didn't seem to care about
it at all and then I went like [ __ ] I'm
worth you know do something about this
and it was kind of this kind of magical
confluence of events that led me to be
able to do that so I wouldn't posit my
ideas on Adele but I you see it quite a
bit in people who become successful and
then lose weight and it's a you know it
could be part of that like confidence
boost when I I have
tens of thousands of private messages on
Instagram which I will never get through
all of them it's just not possible
and every now and again I'll open it and
I'll pick one at random and more
commonly than not it's somebody saying
you made me less ashamed as a fat person
because you seemed to be very successful
and were a very confident fat person
which is not necessarily true I was not
a super confident fat person and now
that you've lost the weight you've
inspired me to also do that that's like
a double whammy yeah Mon [ __ ] don't I
feel good about myself
you know it's not so amazing it's
amazing because I don't think people
should be going around ashamed about
their bodies I think that's not
necessarily good and what my ideas are
about health for myself and even if I
think about what I think is right for
health for other people I don't want to
put that on them and say that anybody
should or should not lose weight however
I think more often than not people have
the idea of wanting to do something and
then feeling incapable of doing it and
so to say like you can do it it's
totally possible with some hard work and
here are these points of inspiration
which you could draw from I think is
only a good thing so I get very torn in
in many directions with like of course
Adele should be patted on the back she's
[ __ ] did something she wanted to do
she didn't do that because somebody said
she was gonna sell more records or
because her boyfriends don't sell more
records than Adele
she's already sold all the records yeah
there you go she's she got to a point in
her life where she what for whatever
reason and who knows what they are she
decided to do this and she did it and
she's happy about it and we should only
applaud her we shouldn't build our
psychosis into her motives or anything
else I think it's not fair
and
I don't know if the men are more give
her more affinity for this goal because
men are genuine generally or
statistically more attractive than women
I have no idea what it is but I see the
same thing as you it's very very
disappoint just layers to it which he
said and it's not just this isn't just
like three or four things being true at
once this is like ten things done
different things being true at once and
as we know people struggle with
complexity it's significantly easier
especially on Twitter you know Twitter
doesn't have the room it actually does
not have the spatial capacity for nuance
your 360 characters something like that
you can put across like a tallies far
adele is thin adele shouldn't have got
thin adele should have got like you know
you you can only do a small number of
these of these stories that you pour
across but man like i think if you have
got messages like that that said not
only have you given me confidence to be
successful at the weight I'm at but then
also to make that transition into being
someone who is a more normal BMI Wow
like that for me is the highest
compliment I could have gotten because I
don't think people are gonna be super
successful at achieving a goal a
physical goal out of shame I just don't
think that's true shame could be early
impetus or whatever I don't know exactly
but I don't think long-term success will
come out of shame I think you need to
have confidence in yourself and your
abilities and work more from that
position I don't know that a lot of
these girls who are body-positive
have never thought I'd be happier look
for me at the end of the day I just want
to fit in an airline seat I just want to
not have to ask for an extension yeah
you know and and there's no part of me
that thinks they need to make airline
seats bigger I think those are built for
averages now as society gets bigger
they will eventually but like even today
the average is say that that's the seat
so you don't need to make a bigger seat
I would rather just have a body that
fits in the average seat that's all you
know there's two approaches when you see
that happen there's one one person who
says good for you and and I want to use
that and another person who says oh my
god
this identifies my shortcoming as long
as Adele or Ethan remain overweight that
justifies my being overweight is they're
able to do it
Oh balls in my court now yeah you know
like one less fat person is one less
person on Team fat yeah I'm one more
person on team I think unfortunately
that we move we seemingly move into the
realm where the group kind of sets the
truth and there is less and less
individual truth and so like if I like
if I like strawberry ice cream and I
think it's the greatest ice cream
nothing you say about strawberry ice
cream can alter my feeling about
strawberry ice cream so I don't see why
anything you say about my feelings about
myself should be able to alter my
feelings about myself but we've gotten
into this space where the group can
dictate how people view themselves and
not only that the grip must dictate how
people view themselves and I go like
you've lost me I can't play that game I
can only know what's true for me
I cannot say what's true for you I will
not say what's true for you but I know
what's true for me and you can offer a
bunch of evidence that may alter my view
of what's true for me that's possible
and I welcome you to do that because I'm
always looking for new
who [ __ ] if I had just stuck with
Kido I wouldn't have the muscle
definition that I have now I just
wouldn't and I'm so happy that I I'm
really pleased with my body right now
that could be sound like the most
[ __ ] materialistic vain thing to say
but I work my ass off and have been for
20 years
on having a body I'm happy with and I'm
like just finally going check me out you
know what I mean like it takes the right
lighting but with the right lighting
I've got a 6-pack that's [ __ ] wild
[Music]
you